here with reaction to all of this is the
author of this incredible new book by
the way defeating big government
socialism i never thought it would get
this bad this fast but it has former
speaker of the house fox news
contributor newt gingrich uh we've got a
very tight race what's fascinating about
this race
just
objectively all three candidates tried
to claim the maga mantle
all three of them ran as trump
candidates whether and oz got the
endorsement but they all still
were clinging to the maga mantle your
thoughts on that
well first of all i think there's not
much room
in most of the republican party for an
anti-trump candidate so i think just to
survive people are going to run
somewhere in the shadow of trump mostly
hoping for his endorsement which of
course dr oz got but i think there's
also a big story on the other side the
democrats in nominating fetterman are
nominating somebody who is a
self-described uh barrier
senator sanders socialist a man who as
chairman of the parole commission
released as many criminals as he could
and felt badly they couldn't get more
criminals out of prison and a man who's
promised to raise taxes on virtually
every pennsylvania family so the choices
fall
whoever wins uh in the primary
is going to be extraordinarily stark and
i suspect the republicans are going to
keep the seat i think for tonight i
don't know enough to to say for sure if
in fact what we're seeing so far is
mostly western pennsylvania then that
would be mccormick's strength
and we'll see
oz get stronger and barnett gets
stronger as the night goes on
the biggest single county for
republicans in plurality is lancaster
and lancaster has had a mistake in how
they counted the
the write-in ballots so they may take a
day or two to actually report it's
conceivable that this will take a few
hours to sort out
but i think
mccormick's done very well uh
particularly for not having been
endorsed by trump us has come on strong
and in all fairness kathy barnett in the
last two weeks has had an amazing surge
uh from a position that no one would
have expected so whoever we nominate i
think is going to be such a clear
alternative to fetterman uh that we will
almost certainly keep the seat this fall
you don't have a do you have a problem
with the the
number of incendiary comments of kathy
to me
i i i would find that in a general
election very difficult to overcome but
that's only my point of view
well look i think i think in the general
election if she's the nominee the
question will be who's more extreme and
fetterman has so many things that he's
already on the extreme left that it will
be a very strange race between two
people who each have a lot of things to
defend against either mccormick or
against dr oz i think that fetterman is
just toast either one of them i think
will beat him and beat him pretty
handily because the choice will just be
so clear
i think of the two frankly dr oz is
stronger in a general election
and i think that trump's nomination as
we see the rural counties come in
we'll see what happens if you'll
remember in ohio just a little while ago
as the republican primary went on some
of the city counties
went for somebody else but the more
small towns and the more rural counties
all went overwhelmingly for the trump
candidate and i think you may see the
same thing happen here as the night goes
on what does it say donald trump came
into the night 58-1 in endorsements now
is he 75-1
that's a pretty good record
well there's no question that
uh whether you like trump or dislike
trump as a matter of just history
no modern political leader has dominated
his party outside of office on the scale
that trump has
and he has a
following in the republican party he's
brought in
an entire generation of people who were
not republican six or seven years ago
who now are part of the republican party
it's an amazing achievement race with 51
percent of the vote in we still got a
long way to go fascinating uh primary
for sure mr speaker thank you we have
more hana